we are here today with one of my
favorite writers of all time in any
medium I am so beyond excited I'm gonna
try to keep it together
we're very calm wouldn't ride Michael
Bendis thank you guys you guys are so
sweet thank you we have studio stowaways
yes everyone knows what's going on thank
you so much for coming
yay I want to kick it off with you
taking over Superman at DC has led to an
entirely new take on the character for
me and a character introduced through
this is Naomi and she lives right
Superman adjacent she fascinates me I
love that the book is framed like a
mystery at the end of every issue when
you first introduce that character to
the publisher was that part of the pitch
like every issues gonna end with that
button yeah it was well well who she is
and what she is and how she relates to
the DC Universe was a 100% what you're
saying that that's what we sold in and
we kind of had this idea that all the
Wonder comics had like a Superman
there's a Superman connection to each
one of them but in a way only the
audience will know like the characters
don't go oh a Superman connects all of
this yeah but but I do think there's
like a way that Superman and or Batman
and/or Wonder Woman can sometimes affect
a lot more than they think like they're
there they're this this they're more
than just a person they're yeah it's oh
it's so like the idea that Superman
bouncing into a small town for a second
could create so much story that he's not
involved in that's like it was very
exciting to me yeah humanizes them
without him being a part of the story
necessarily yeah but also just describes
what you know and I I guess that was a
little surprising I didn't realize how
few stories like this were at DC that
were we have stories that take place in
Metropolis and Gotham but there are
other places that we don't get to see
what it feels like to be living in a
world with a million Green Lantern's and
yeah and so so to give us a new
perspective was really exciting I'm so
overwhelmed by people's response to her
and it
that I I David and Jamal and I Idris to
stare at each other go WOW okay because
it it is coming from a very personal
place like I said like we were bleeding
on the page almost like and almost it
almost feels I got like we're building
like a like a punk rock song in our
garage and you're hearing it live like
it's so freshly out of us that you see
it and the response is so enormous that
it's it's the most unique experience
we've ever had your garage rock is
arriving immediately on the largest
stadium so but it is I think it's a part
of the appeal of comics still even
though this TV shows and movies
everywhere we go is that the comics are
still made with almost like a punk rock
dy I kind of you know even Marvel and DC
Comics are really like people can you
can feel the blood sweat and tears on
them yeah and it's a trademark of yours
to apply this kind of thinking this sort
of how these wonderful fictional
universes affect the people who live in
them as you've demonstrated for quite an
impressive body of work before you your
recent arrival at DC I may I ask the the
big question after just just a legendary
run doing some of our favorite runs over
at Marvel co-creating Jessica Jones
right co-writing writing ultimate
spider-man with ultimate spider-man
everybody ultimate for it the reason I'm
at this desk is ultimate spider-man
thank you you landed a DC just about a
year ago I think all right we're what
like I came here a year ago like this
week so it's almost anniversary its but
even though I have technically been
since like a year ago watching and you
so you have three branches that you're
simultaneously doing over DC you've got
jinx world if you're incredible
independence DC independence that wing
of things you've got the Wonder Comics
imprint which we're very much both in
love with and you've got the work you're
doing on friggin Superman in action
comics and the upcoming Leviathan event
so that's a lot is there anything that
jumps out that you want to like I want
to get into all of it but first of all
we want to tell us a little bit about
Leviathan yeah let's let's talk about
that because it is really it touches on
everything you just discussed some
jigsaw the first but on
so when I first sat down with Dan to do
and we have that hey are we gonna make
comics together do we like each other
but we were talking about like things we
could do when stories that could be told
then and one thing that he said to me he
goes you know there's one thing about DC
the shape of DC that's always been a
struggle for me we have like 40
fictional organizations that basically
do the same thing and it actually is
very messy as a literary device it
actually is difficult for some of the
other writers now they were all created
out of a good place it was all creator
going I'm gonna make a thing so I don't
bother the other thing but now there's
five six things so so you said it was
like a story like a like a like a like a
spy thriller where all these things I'm
long and I said but no but you don't
want to just like knock down a bunch of
stuff but something arises out of it
that that was kind of the the purpose of
all of this that could be pretty cool
and what has to push back against it
could be something unique but well we
have to make sure it's something that we
don't see already at Marvel or DC what
I'm more interested in let's take some
chances let's let's try so there's
there's like heroes and villains and
then there's this other thing and he's
not playing by any of the rules he or
she is not playing by any of the rules
it's gonna say we get a pronoun trouble
all the time in them wrong half the time
but but uh but whoever is behind that
mask has an agenda that is that is that
is not in conflict with the heroes and
villains it is a different thing and
that different thing could be that
that's work it's fascinating like if
you're not on board with this what I
what I what are you on board now this
big of a web because you're dealing with
so many characters you're intentionally
planning so many seeds you're shaping
this so broadly is your house like
Beautiful Mind with notes and things you
have the strings like how do you shape
that much detail I don't do that kids
and stuff there is that but it is it is
a it is a nerds paradise like you you
you can't imagine it's it's it's it's
lovely I do I get a lot of inspiration
from things
IIIi think I posted recently a my
personal jewelry collection since coming
to DC has like quadruple
I have no rings now I have a legion ring
a class ring have some rings so but no
but this story what's happening is
someone is taking out all of the big
organizations there you wake up and
they're gone like there's no there's no
conflict it is just wiped out someone
has done this and they've done it with
so much power and so much behind them
that how could they have possibly put
all this together without any of the
heroes or organizations knowing about it
so that's the story of over Anna man yes
absolutely so what's going on in extra
comics right now is we're watching
Amanda Waller's world collapse around
her a world of which she made the rules
and someone is not playing by them so
what that does is set up for all the
heroes now have to get together and go
there was something called the via thing
it has caused major destruction and in
the morning it's clearly going to reveal
what it's doing to replace what it has
destroyed so we have to figure out who
this is and what they've done and how
they've done it before the morning so
Batman and Lois Lane put together a
group of what they think are the best
detectives for this case to get together
and figure out not only who the suspects
are to be Leviathan but they are all
suspects they are all legitimate
suspects so they have to unsuspecting
selves and figure out who the bad guy is
it is someone we know there's someone in
the DC Universe is someone who's existed
before it is not Naomi okay you know
five issues
that's the only clue yeah go ahead you
get to reinterpret these characters in
these universes with a lot of freedom
when you bring an artist on board do you
shape the structure of the type of story
like Malev is perfect for detective work
right story a great question because
this is this storyline was made only for
Alex this makes me this was made
specifically to give him a platform to
which to explode I know that he wanted
to do this like when I Mike came to DC I
called some friends and go hey we're
taking our crater on book to DC or hey
I'm going to DC wanna come and with with
Alex I knew we had a history together
years and years ago DC had called us and
said come do Batman
you know like a blank check oh right
true we couldn't do it at the time I was
under contract and was a lovely author
but both of us didn't want to do Batman
that would hurt that one's a sliding
door as a moment excuse me so so we
would think about like if we ever get
that and so all of a sudden slowly over
the course of years the chance came and
I know how much it meant to him I know
he he wants to be one of the great
Batman artists of all time so I just
make sure I create a story that lets him
fly and I think people can tell from
Detective Comics 1000 yeah all the way
from here to there
Alex is on fire and and he's never but
this is everyone we've been talking to
you like in our community was like oh my
god what's going on with Alex so it's
it's it's pretty special I'm pretty
excited about it and the rienne what
I've done to the story that made it
special for Alex is that and on top of
it being for Alex I was also thinking
about the shape of events and these kind
of stories these summer events and and
some of them I've done them have a
almost a disaster movie feel to them
like oh my god something blew up on page
3 and we're gonna be dealing with it
further for the rest of the series this
is a different kind of thing this is a
whodunit this is I mean this is a
thriller a mystery this is in the
shadows this is people getting together
and it's more like a death trap or
Murder on the Orient Express than it is
you consider a traditional like event
Express they all did it I'm calling it
now everybody survived like like like
like like they're in a room and the
clues are there yeah they have to figure
it out and they're all smarter than the
other person they all have a very unique
specific agenda a point of view and I'm
excited about it and also it helps helps
me get across my philosophy that Lois
Lane is the most dangerous most
interesting person and all of comics and
this will be another chapter proving
that not that anyone needed my help
moment I heard that you were coming to
DC my brain went oh my god Lois why it
was always great because we already had
greg rucka taking over Lois in our
pocket beforehand you have okay the
Superman Leviathan rising special is
coming out and spinning out a Matt
Fraction Jimmy Olsen series in a Greg
Rucka Lois Lane series and clearly I
have slipped into a coma
well hilariously may I say and I don't
mean get too grim but I you know I had a
near-death experience about a year ago
and I don't mean to bring it down but
these people were in my hospital room
greg rucka would sit in my I was blinded
at one point Greg work was just sitting
there whispering to me about Superman
just keeping my mind off it right yeah I
don't mean it really was special it's
also one of those you're great friends
are just way better friends and you
thought they were leaving them to be
that great so we were having these great
conversations about Superman and Lois
Lane and Jimmy Olsen and I'm like boy
and at a time where I didn't think I was
getting out they kind of told me I
wasn't leaving so it was like nah I
could get to see these so here I am a
year later and not only do I get to see
them but they're it's great as I thought
they were gonna be everyone is coming at
it with like full-blown you know all
their passion and for everyone's asking
about Jimmy Olsen all they want to know
is that Hawkeye good
it's Hawkeye good yeah yeah that's what
you're asking that's what's your good
wishes filmin to that level is
impressive there's a lot of emotion
behind the scenes with this stuff that
is sometimes isn't necessary but there
but it there's a lot of friendship and
passion
and a lot of us feeling a lot of intense
passion about the characters themselves
and our feelings about Lois Lane and
what a journalist is in this in this
life and how Lois can really project
what a journalist life is in literature
maybe better than anybody right now it's
pretty exciting and you've already
introduced very interesting taken those
characters in those first few issues of
Action Comics and I really like that you
showed Amanda Waller's strength by show
in your weakness like yeah she played
some cards that I didn't expect and then
she was still not able to handle some
things is that something we can expect
of this this type of book where you see
there's so much dialogue that shapes the
action and when you're writing these for
certain artists you mentioned how you're
giving Malev has his beautiful Batman
story he can give you more in a shadow
of that then the most artists can with
the biggest fight scene ever yeah like
you look at that you're I get an
emotional response from that I do I
don't know other people do as well and
you don't you can just dig into the
characters then what is that a shorthand
you develop by working with like what
you were able to do with ultimate 13
with that storytelling because you and
Bagley have worked together and continue
to work together and cover which I've
got to talk about cover is a story that
effectively reimagine how I saw comics
as a medium laughs I didn't imagine
you'd be able to tell two such disparate
stories simultaneously and then have
that beautiful weave at the end so it's
it's a really interesting take on comic
books and David Mack's the only guy I
could see doing anything close to it but
you'd have to have so much history with
your artists yeah is there a moment when
you're like wait this is my guy for this
well it's a few things and with when
David and I we grew up together we had
all these experiences together we did
all you know like all the way back so we
we we have a shared experience also and
we are completely two different humans
from two different universes to so when
we come together to make comics it's a
very special thing for both of us we're
both bringing something to the table the
other person just doesn't have just like
we just a life experience the other
person doesn't have I also with with
people like Alex and David and
Mark Bagley before to everyone so while
you're faced with an artist who you see
they know what they're doing but I bet
if you push them in this to this they
could get to that other thing I bet
there's something else there maybe they
can't see it and I've been wrong too I
push artists and like I don't wanna do
this but but every once awhile you go
let's try this and they go oh my god I
love that thank you that was that I
didn't know I like that about myself and
that like just I know where but you're
Tina Fey and Mean Girls and you're a
pusher but like like like with badly was
doing like all these cool superhero
comics right and then as I was doing
that first year of ultimate spider-man
with him I would see that the quieter
moments where I would really like dig in
with the high school stuff he was really
bringing it like a lot of subtext and
emotion like like like you like a lot of
thought was being brought into the
facial expression and I'm like I have
people don't let him do that a lot like
like I wonder if he wants to when people
just haven't given him the opportunity
or what not and that like I wrote that
issue and I go if he hates this you know
I was dry with conjecting idea when I
wanted him to be and then instead I got
I got that wonderful experience that
everyone got to have which is oh he's
very good in fact it's a one-act play
and he directed it and he directed it
beautifully I love like yeah you know so
so and with with David he and I
originally were going to do a comic book
just about like the history of comics or
like the 90s what it's like to be an
independent comic guy in the 90s because
what's interesting about that is how
many of us grew up and are now making
mainstream successful tentpole things
yes the garage bands are running the
studio
there's always generational things like
that and like there was like in the
sixties they had that in the film but in
there's something interesting going on
in comics where a lot of the voices of
the 90s of comics are the voices of
cinema right now on some level I wanted
we were gonna like dig into that a
little bit but instead we got into the
the idea of cover because at the same
time I got invited to speak at Langley
and then I got asked to go to Bolivia
for the State Department because it was
interesting they were having a
a cultural exchange like the
government's don't get along but the in
Bolivia they love American superheroes
and culture it's all Batman and
spider-man and they go come down to the
biggest book fair in the world and
engage right and so what we were there
and then David was getting invited to go
to the State Department to teach art in
Russia and Cuba and all these places he
went so we were getting a lot of stuff
was happening a lot of information a lot
of stuff so cover actually came out of
real stuff that's a based on a true
story I know there's more true in there
than people think and also there was
nothing funnier than last week an
awesome con CIA opened had a table do
you know about this yeah CIA put it
opened a table at the convention I'm
taking a lot of credit for that
I said that article to David they was
and should we be using our powers for
something else and can I can I get a
sandwich comics series about the Peace
Corps series comes out next month
exactly I do say before we've entirely
left behind the subject of ultimate
spider-man I have to ask a little bit
since our it's our first chance to have
you on here you know there's a Miles
Morales movie yeah there's a Jessica
Jones and Netflix that's crazy what has
it been like to watch these very
personal brain children go out in
Congress well they're very personal and
that and that you're saying right there
the fact that there are such high
quality interpretations of these
characters and so true to our intention
is the deepest relief I will ever have
like it's hard to describe you you've
got to be Zen about it there's 100 like
even when you're making it yourself
there's so many pieces you try your
hardest and you you'll do your best and
it'll work or it won't right
so when other people are doing it it's
if you have to be even more Zen I in all
you hope like I like I hope everyone's
hearts in the right place I hope
everyone's you know and then
I have had this experience of oh this is
more than not sucking this is something
special is is very very unique and I I
can't get over how lucky I am in this
area because this is just luck and even
this weekend having like ronan on screen
that's like that's like if you made a
list of like the five things the
internet beats the hell out of me for me
just I mean they're all on screen now
and it's it's so weird to me so when
people yell at me about stuff any that I
go it's hard for me to hear it this
weekend so I took my son six years old
right and I was like I hope he sits
through this whole thing because I want
to sit through the whole man and he did
he was like literally crawled up in my
lap and sat there and like you know he's
sick so you have to talk him through a
couple of things right and then we've
got to Ronan I'm so yeah like this is
one of Danny's actually this is like
this before you were born like I had
Hawkeye get all management's and then my
son who actually is not allowed to have
any guns or knives in the house you know
it looked at me like oh so hog he gets
murder sores so it's not only am I
getting this experience but I get to
share it with my kids at that age where
they're just getting to understand it
and it's all awesome and so it's really
really special and I I spend a lot of
time writing thank you notes to other
filmmakers and writers who who just just
make me look great and it's really it's
really nice yeah and I even like I wrote
a note to the the Rodney who wrote
spider-verse and I wrote him a very
impassioned thank you what he wrote back
was so much better like well yeah but
that's why now with the spider-man
leading into this universe like your
last issue of Myles was like a bottle
episode that ultimate 13 I keep
mentioning do you have any plans after
Leviathan this giant sweeping hell yeah
you have bottle episodes plan for these
certain characters now you have access
to know what was he part of this is
we're kind of
Riaan reinventing you to meet the
question and the answer and Plastic Man
and green arrow like I know everyone has
relationship with these characters some
people do some people don't and every
once a while it's nice to like kind of
bring them out and go these are really
cool characters and you want like like
like we know we know you're coming for
Batman but I think a for the quiz I
think you're gonna stay for the question
I do I really do so and I've had that
before even when I was writing
adventures you know that people are
buying Avengers - spider-man's on it but
then they like Luke Cage like if I do
mind if I do my job and tell my story
right that I can introduce so the plan
is that these characters if they aren't
Leviathan themselves will well the clock
ran out we were like is there a moment
is there it's so high - I will say that
people do this to me online all the time
they try to trick me into answering
something like listen this is not my
first already oh yeah all that let's say
can you just tell me this person isn't
this which is basically yeah that's a
spoiler spoiler a reverse they trying to
hit me with a reverse spoiler right yeah
I try to avoid the scoops cuz I want to
read the thing I want to go in there's a
bummer because I wrote what's a wild
like some like a rumor will hop up but
just complete nonsense - someone just
completely made up on four families yeah
we made it up and they want me to come
out and say no and and I can't because
if I say no to that but I didn't say no
to this I'm like so I have to like be
spoiler-free
a slippery slope of internet culture so
I know yeah it is it's also when we're
in the middle of a mystery and my
darling Fred Greg Rucka many years ago
said the worst thing you can do in
comics is a mystery because if you have
thousands of readers they're all online
and engage yeah and they're all guessing
so someone's gonna guess right and then
everyone's gonna read that guess and go
oh I guess no you just read his guts
that's yeah so but but I've taken that
into consideration as we have crafted
this story I can't wait to see what that
means this summer I could not be more
excited I can't wait for the mystery
unfold
I can't wait to not know what's going on
but most of all I cannot wait to pick up
Leviathan check it out right now this
summer I can't wait to see you're taken
so many characters I thank you thank you
so very much for joining us and
hopefully by the end of this weekend we
can compare notes of what I
they happen to awesome thank you so much